Welcome back to "Drew's News."
I'm Keke Palmer.
And this next one is perfect for beauty week, okay.
It's all about how to use your eyes to hypnotize.
The Cut reports, TikToker Michelle Diaz
says that the white dot makeup trick
will make people fall in love with you.
I mean, this is crazy, guys.
She swears by it.
She says, all you gotta do is take white eyeliner
and put your four dots around each eye.
I mean, Ross you seem like you
already getting ready to do it, you-
No, hold on, I'm no dummy.
So you do, oh, okay.
That's a big dot, love.
Thank you so much for noticing.
Okay, here we go.
Like this, right?
Yeah, yeah.
This is what she did?
I don't think,
(audience laughing loudly)
What do you think?
I mean, well, you got messy with it.
Well, I beg your pardon, I'm like.
(Drew and audience laughing loudly)
I mean, don't know how to-
I mean, I was already
in love with you a little bit.
I don't know how much more,
look at me one more time, let me see.
Well.
(audience laughing loudly)
(audience applauds loudly)
I mean, is there anything.
I don't think I did it right.
Will you just fix my dot?
Yeah, you got that smudge going.
Can I see her picture, how did she do it?
So she did one at the top, one at the bottom
and one in the two sides like you did.
I think though also like when you-
And it doesn't move, this is a heavy eyeliner.
You have to let it, you have to like let your eyes dry
because if you blink,
Oh 'cause he moved them
too much.
It's gonna double that.
(Keke blows raspberry)
Bye.
I look like a clown.
(audience applauds loudly)
There are elements of it that look really good.
Really?
That side's really good.
This side, okay, I-
Yeah, 'cause it's.
'Kay.
'Cause the way she does it, is really subtle.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I look insane.
Now, something
that I developed at Flower Beauty,
this was really important to me,
is I wanted to develop a white mascara.
It's actually-
That's very fashion.
Really pretty, really attractive, very soft.
And with the holidays coming up, it's called Snow Queen.
You can get your #WhiteLashes on
with a red lip and feel super holiday.
I love the hair movement with,
that made me feel really good, like.
I have to tell you, every time I wear it,
I feel pretty, I feel attractive.
So I'm really, I'm like trying to start this trend.
We'll see if it catches on.
Okay, what do you think?
Ooh, yes.
Come on.
Did it work?
Hi.
I'm like all in.
Well actually you do
look really cute.
Pile more on, Rossy, I do like four layers.
You actually do look really, really cute though.
Yeah.
I have to say I'm feeling pretty fabulous.
Maybe I should go to a disco tonight.
(Keke and Drew exclaim loudly)
Well, how about this?
We've got the latest home decor trend.
"Vogue" says people are decorating their living spaces
with disco balls.
Oh, really.
Yeah, we've all missed going out,
but you know, it shows, right.
We need to have a little fun.
Interior designers are domesticating the disco ball,
bringing it into living rooms and dens.
Look at this.
Drew, can we get a disco ball here, please?
Can we?
I don't know. Can we, Rossy?
Please, one day, could we get a disco ball?
Sammy Sullivan?
Can we?
Can we get disco balls?
Come on, Sammy.
One day, can we.
(audience applauds loudly)
Whoa.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I love it!
(audience applauds loudly)
(Ross laughs loudly)
Oh, my God, be careful.
I was just saying we need to bring the disco back.
Come out there, come out here.
I need to dance.
I wanna dance.
I wanna dance too.
(audience applauds loudly)
I love it, I can get into this trend.
Bringing old school, bringing old school.
Thank you.
Doesn't it feel good?
Yeah.
Oh, I love it.
Keke Palmer, I love you.
I love you, I love you.
Rossy!
I love you, I love you, I love you.
(audience applauds loudly)
You guys!
We love you, we love you, we love you.
And we will be right back.
Yeah.
(mellow pop music)